hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we are here with a another
money-making method this will be episode
number 7 this is going to be a money
making method that is definitely very
dependent on prices as most of my guides
are so before we get into this before
you dislike the video for whatever
reason that you have I'm going to I'm
going to say this this isn't a
money-making method that you can do
necessarily all the time if you want
something that you can do all the time
check out my last videos on death runes
the prices I'm sure have gone down since
the video however there still are a
viable method you could probably make at
least a mil an hour and it's very low
requirement so check that out now if you
want something that could potentially be
a bit more GP per hour but in a shorter
time or if you want to get some magic XP
- feel free to stick along with me I
just like to lay all this out there for
you guys I know it's a long intro but I
always get so many comments of people
complaining so I just want to put that
out there so what we're going to be
doing today is charging different types
of jewelry because I found recently
there are at least with one thing right
now you can make money charging amulets
of glory and it's actually a pretty
substantial amounts almost five hundred
six hundred GP per charge and you get
like eighty magic XP so I'm going to try
these out for a few different types of
jewelry and see what we can come back
with if it's just amulets of glory then
obviously that's all we're going to have
but I'm hoping I could find something
with a couple different ones so we'll be
back in a second with a little bit of a
meth and stuff on what you can do for
money alright so the first thing I'm
going to throw out there right now is
that Dragonstone amulets you are 20k or
20k and 500 GP and a ball of wool is 50
GP so realistically you're spending 20k
and 550 GP on each one and I'm just
going to throw some of these together
and see how much money I can make in a
short amount of time because I'm pretty
sure that this is actually going to be
decently profitable I honestly once this
video goes up some of these may not work
and I understand that just work your way
around to find other ones that you can
do but I'm just showing some examples
and trying to be helpful so please just
accept it for what it is I'm really
trying I don't I don't know people get
bit Smith
so as you can see here we get a little
bit of construction um [__] we get a
little bit of crafting XP I'm just going
to kind of show you guys what I'm going
to be doing so as you saw I pretty much
bought this for 20k and 500 GP for the
most part I mean balls of wool are
pretty much irrelevant so after that I'm
going to just go ahead and grab out
these cosmics and show you guys what
else you can then do which is charge
each one of these cosmic things or
charge each one of these Dragonstone
amulets and I'll kind of show you guys
how much money I made just off of this
one inventory and then I'll test it out
even a little more and see how much we
can make in an hour and how much XP I
guess you could expect to get from doing
this but now I'm going to show you guys
what they are worth they're worth 21 9s
for 6 however I was able to insist out
one a second ago for at least or it was
22 K so that would mean off of each
amulet by doing this we were able to
make I mean you have to include the cost
of one cosmic rune I guess which is 150
GP so you had that on it costs us 20.7 K
to buy each one of these and then I can
sell them on instantly for a 1.3 K
profit which is actually pretty
impressive that I was able to make 15
well actually more than 15k probably
like 17 18 K just in this one inventory
alright so here we are back from about 5
minutes of doing some amulets of glory I
was able to get around 100 I was also
using the balls of wool on the unstrung
necklaces and then charging them as well
there are two different ways you can go
about this if you want more magic XP you
could just charge the dragon stone
amulets um the K the cosmic runes a cost
you 140 P so you'll end up making 600
per one and you probably would have
doubled this the one thing you will need
is a mud battle staff that's just so
that you don't have to waste all of the
earth and water runes to be able
actually cast a spell so basically what
I ended up doing I just bought the
dragon stone amulets you because there
was more margin to be made since I'd be
making a little bit more actually
turning them into amulets which takes
about the same amount of time as let's
click intensive so basically in five
minutes what I was able to do was I
bought I guess you could say 95 of these
in total all of the supplies the ball of
wool and the chaos room cost me 200 GP
so the total price was 20k and 700 GP
and these are able to sell on and
as you can see here we're going to insta
my glory I can sell them on for 22050 so
we're going to sell all but one on for
that there we go to mill in 94 K and if
I do a little bit of math on it here in
a second so did a little bit of math and
the total price for what I was able to
do came down to a hunt or what it cost
me to actually do this came down to 1.96
6 mil so in total I was able to make
pretty much 130 K in 5 minutes I would
be able to make 1.5 to 1.6 million this
method now as I said earlier this
obviously all depends on how much of a
supply there actually is for this item
that's one thing that's going to have to
be huge and that's one thing that you
guys have to realize is unless you guys
want me to put out like your average
money making method and what you kill
green dragons or kill Zora there's
there's going to be the factor of making
a lot of money but not being able to do
it for hours on end alright so yeah
we're going to go on now I'm probably
just going to try actually just charging
I guess charging unstrung or uncharged
dragons own ambulance so yeah we're
gonna do that real quick alright so here
we are five minutes later and what did
we end up getting as you can see we have
a hundred fifty-eight Glory's charge and
this is the amount that it costed us or
god damn it the amount that it cost us
ah whatever that was the amount that it
cost us and this is the overall amount
so as you can see a meal oops of glory
here okay it's not going to show the
price whatever
so the overall of what these are
actually worth is three three point four
eight 3k so as you can see here that is
99 K more than we had initially invested
in it so 99 K times twelve which is how
much you could do this per hour this is
pretty much 1.2 mil DP per hour however
the one thing you do also have to you
know just understand is that I also was
able to gain twelve point three K in
this amount of time so you're looking at
about a hundred forty five K magic XP an
hour doing this method assuming that it
works obviously after this video it's
going to be kind of rough but if you
just keep this in the back of your mind
all the time and just always be checking
prices whenever you get this idea in
your head I'm sure you can find margins
and it's just insane how much magic XP
you can get while still making a ton of
money
one of the best magic like this is one
of the best magic XP methods and you
also make complete bank nonetheless hope
that video was helpful hope this money
making guide gives you guys some ideas I
know I know
after the skits if it if this video gets
big enough then it's just going to be
ruined but you can apply these same sort
of things to what else you want to find
in a GE so hope this video is helpful if
the West feel free to hit a like if you
guys have any way you want me to improve
so if you dislike the video bye heavy
way you want me to improve please tell
me about it down below or else I cannot
fix it and cannot help you more and yeah
if you guys want to be first informed
and no one know the best money making
methods as soon as I put them out to you
guys feel free to that sub button then
the last hope you guys have a wonderful
day and be sure gonna ruin another
money-making message just like those
[__] ducks